et toujours aux etats-unis cette enquête
choc du new york times autour des
agissements de l'armée américaine les
frappes dites de précision contre
daraîche en afghanistan en syrie ou
encore en irak aurait causé la mort de
milliers de civils depuis 2014
contrairement aux chiffres avancés par
le pentagone est les précisions avec
notre correspondant à washington tom
abonnés le drone cette arme du 21e
siècle était censé faire entrer l'armée
américaine dans la modernité fini les
milliers de militaires au sol place aux
frappes chirurgicales lancés depuis les
airs sur des cibles précisément désigner
celui qui a acté ce changement de
doctrine c'est barack obama hier en 2014
d'autoriser les frappes aériennes en
irak oui nous pouvons agir prudemment et
de façon responsable pour empêcher un
potentiel actes de génocide c'est ce que
nous faisons sur cette montagne par
conséquent j'ai autorisé des frappes
aériennes ciblées si nécessaire pour
aider les forces en irak alors qu'elle
se bat pour briser le siège du monde
sinjar et protéger les civils piégés là
bas
sauf que ces bombardements ont provoqué
des centaines de pertes civiles au cours
des dernières années des faits déjà
exposés par julian assange dans le
tristement célèbre collatérales des reds
en 2007 des pilotes à bord d'un
hélicoptère en irak avaient ouvert le
feu tuant au moins 18 personnes à
l'image de ces informations dévoilées
par le lanceur d' alerte il est toujours
très difficile d'avoir accès aux
véritables chiffres sur les erreurs de
l'armée américaine le new york times a
donc lancé plusieurs procédures en
invoquant la loi sur la transparence
dans les administrations pour obtenir
des milliers de documents officiellement
le pentagone reconnaît que 1400 17
civils ont été tués accidentellement au
cours des opérations en irak et en syrie
depuis 2014 selon lé rapport consulté
par le new york times ce bilan est très
nettement sous-estimé les enquêtes des
autorités américaines seraient
superficielles et les sanctions à
l'encontre des responsables quasi
inexistante dernier exemple en date une
frappe menée le 29 août dernier à kaboul
et qui a provoqué la mort de dix civils
dont sept enfants après avoir nié dans
un premier temps le pentagone a dû
reconnaître qu'il s'agissait d'une
erreur pour autant aucune poursuite ne
sera engagée
aucune de leurs recommandations ne
portait spécifiquement sur des questions
de responsabilité
le ministre a lu leurs recommandations
je ne vais pas les aborder tout
certaines cela peut se comprendre sont
classifiés mais il a approuvé leurs
recommandations donc je ne m'attends pas
à ce que des responsabilités
personnelles soit engagée concernant la
frappe aérienne du 29 août
des cas similaires se sont produits à de
très nombreuses reprises ces dernières
années quand les faits sont rendus
publics souvent les autorités
américaines présentent formellement
leurs excuses mais les procédures
disciplinaires sont très rares et
l'indemnisation des victimes les taux
sont à mon avis il devrait être puni
parce que des enfants mais pas des
membres de groupes extrémistes ont été
tués dans cette attaque ils ont fait des
erreurs mais les états unis acceptent
tout cela donc quand ils font une erreur
il devrait payer le prix est indemnisé
car les civils tués était innocent sous
couvert d'une nouvelle doctrine l'armée
américaine a donc provoqué de très
nombreuses pertes civiles l'opacité
autour de ces faits et l'absence de
sanction de quoi interroger le retrait
des troupes au sol au moyen-orient
pourrait conduire à une recrudescence
dans les années à venir du recours aux
frappes aériennes avec les risques
collatéraux que cela comporte